[Music]
foreign
larry thank you for being on the show
happy to be here you know i have to say
that most that you know
with the background that you have i see
it a lot in meetings in the company that
i work for
but usually it's a virtual background
because they want to seem like they're
in a government office
for you it's not a virtual background
it's an actual background yeah i
actually came to city hall today uh
definitely i've been sheltering in place
the majority of the time that being said
you know every now and then i do need to
come in and get to the backlog of actual
physical mail that i get on
on a weekly basis of course so larry
mayor of sunnyvale
let's just jump into it what is it like
being mayor so
it's very interesting so i was um
elected a council in 2016
uh chosen as mayor in january of 2019
and it's uh so our council ends up
choosing the mayor every two years
and so being there has been a lot of fun
uh you realize
that you don't have that much power as
mayor you realize
that you run the council meetings
you meet with the city manager to set
the agendas but other than that
it's basically like being on council but
your one big power is networking people
together
and so especially during the time of
covet 19 networking the right people
together
is a critical thing in the community you
know you are
counselor in chief so you know we have a
police chief who
who is in charge of public safety uh
this
the the manager this is the you know the
city manager who
runs uh the city staff but the mayor the
mayor's there to hear
you know people's issues people's
questions and you know make people
feel safe or answer you know what what
their what
when they have what's going to happen
you know making making sure that they're
feeling
you know fine in their community sure so
so just for for whoever doesn't and
doesn't know when i for example don't
know what is it what is a council
in the context of of you know let's say
sunnyvale
city council absolutely so uh the
majority of the
cities uh in california have a council
of
five to nine uh council members and some
sometimes depending on the city they
have a directly elected mayor
and we're actually moving to a directly
elected mayor from a sunnyvale
standpoint
but those those council members um
set the policies at the priorities for a
city
and then the majority of the cities then
they have a city manager
who reports to council and a city
attorney who reports to council
and the city manager implements the
directives of council
based upon you know their management
experience
and so the council is select is elected
from every city and it's normally a
four-year term depending upon your city
so you know some cities have directly
elected mayor some of them
the councils uh themselves choose what
happens
uh we meet twice a month at least twice
a month
to uh have staff reports review what's
going on in the city
you know new study issues you know
approve
the normal bills all that all the
standard operations of the city
do the different council members have
different responsibilities or
jurisdictions
within the city you know scope or
are they more like board members where
they have voting power on
every given issue so right now uh so two
things
uh right now our council is at large the
entire council
is represents every council member
represents the entire city
uh we're actually moving to districts in
the november 2020 election
so that you know six of the council
members each
each uh council member will represent
one-sixth the city
and then we'll have a directly elected
mayor who represents the
entire city but each council member gets
a vote
on all city matters and so it's it's one
of seven and so even as
as mayor you don't have a lot of
additional power you have to build that
coalition
which is sometimes an issue because the
brown act but but
you know every council member uh should
represent
uh the needs and the questions the
entire city
no that makes a lot of sense and you
know so obviously we're in a fascinating
time
and i have the privilege of speaking now
to to the mayor of a city
that has so many great you know tech and
companies that are making incredible
strides both and in terms of helping
people
in the new norms but also in finding
ways to combat this
this pandemic so what what is it how
how is your day-to-day job different now
than it was
let's say three months ago sure so
definitely
a lot more um conference calls just like
this one
but the biggest thing is um staying up
to date on what's happening at the
federal at the state
the county level you know we have
conference calls
uh from an elected standpoint you know
private conference calls with county
officials
like every other day but then it's the
press releases and often
conflicting press releases at the state
level with the county level
or the federal level you know staying up
to date on all that is
is really important and then uh from a
from a council member standpoint you
know i also have a day job so if you're
in san jose or san francisco
it's a full-time job and full-time pay
the majority of the cities around
around the bay area um that's just a you
know council member is a part-time job
so a lot of us have day jobs also so i
have
you know jumping from from council from
conference calls
as mayor to conference calls as a
program manager at my startup
is uh the mix of the day whoa whoa whoa
hold on
larry wait wait you're the program
manager at a startup while you're a
mayor
absolutely so the majority of council
you know so we have
half of our council members are you know
working in full-time jobs right now
and because it's what the what the city
pays you is a stipend it's not a
full-time salary
you know we have one city staff member
that that helps schedule and manage
all of our all of our all the council
members you know issues and questions
and all that
but yeah it's it and we're one of the
better paid you know
stipend cities but that being said you
know it's not a full-time job it's not a
full-time wage
so so tell me just a little bit about
what is the startup that you're doing
yeah so i i work at a battery charging
startup
so i'm a software engineer by
by training so i'm a you know bachelor
in computer science
i've moved into director and you know
manager director
i'm currently a program manager at a a
battery charging software company
called qnovo and so what we do is
uh make lithium ion cells extend the
life
you know make sure that the battery
health is is very good
and so we were in over 100 million bones
between
sony and lg and that same cell that
that's in
a cell phone is is exactly what's in an
ev an electric vehicle and so we have a
lot of interest from multiple
automakers because they're moving into
the ev world
and extending the battery life is really
critical from
an ev standpoint because when you're
talking about
a cell phone you know every two or three
years people throw away their cell phone
replace their cell phone
you know the the expectation that the
auto from an auto industry standpoint is
you'll have that same car 10 years from
now and when you have a pack of 100
cells
you know it's critical to make sure that
that life that you're
that you're not going to have to replace
you know every battery pack every
four or five years from a from an
automotive standpoint because
in ev one third of the cost of an ev
is that battery pack no i i think
i think it's just you know it's it's
incredible how you know on one hand
we can talk for a minute about in your
with them
with the head of a mayor and then all of
a sudden you're a program manager and a
director and
as in an engineering startup i think
that's just that's incredible
and so talk to me a little bit about
this this dissonance
so how do you go about you know both
serving the
city and you're you have a leadership
role and you know i'm looking at the
facebook live that you're doing now
weekly with your
with the city and you're answering
questions live for an hour and i think
it's
i think it's it's a wonderful endeavor
and you know you can see that people are
looking at you as some sort of
comfort figure and you know you're a
person that's representing
representing this pandemic from the
federal and governmental standpoint
right so how do you deal with this this
dissonance
so you know the good thing is i'm
program manager so
i get to decide when a lot of the
meetings are you know it's an
international startup so
so i have a lot of calls in the morning
you know with europe
i have evening calls with asia so so i
i'm able to kind of balance that
and juggle the different meetings during
the day uh as far as not trying trying
not to conflict with my counsel and
mayor's
mayor's job uh that being said you know
there's a lot of phone calls
it's it is it is a big task because you
know
being that counselor there's a lot of
you know calling people back in
and i'll be honest you know you know i i
don't call back people back immediately
you know if
i answer the call if i can but there is
the expectation especially during
you know the time the pandemic that
people understand
you see how they can help you know all
that's really important
definitely definitely so i mean a little
bit about
your take on on this on this trajectory
because
the way that i approach this
conversation is i assumed
that when people take the role of a
mayor or city council
because it's because they see they see
it as a stepping stone
later on in politics and to get you know
governor or senator
and eventually get you know possibly to
the white house is that how you see it
or is this something that you're just
passionate about
because you love the city so for me it's
just uh you know
i never thought i'd be mayor or let
alone council member
you know i was i was nine years on the
planning commission before you know
before deciding to run for council and
i was six years on the planning
commission that finished in 2010 and at
that point people said
run for city council and i'm like i
would never want that job i'm not a
politician
once i got back on planning commission
because they needed people
i saw that you know having that that
experience in
the main reason you run for council is
because you love your city
right now being mayor during these times
you know
comforting people you know as much as as
much as
it can be an extra burden you know i
feel i'm very well placed and have
reached out to a lot of
you know diverse communities within our
city to make sure that they feel
safe you know i'm i'm i'm delivering
face masks to
the county shelter i'm you know that
networking that
that you know loving your city however
however you can help out and that's one
of the reasons why
you step up to run for city council or
mayor
i don't see you know moving beyond you
know to other elected
higher elected um positions you know for
me it's it's
you know it's serving my community and
that's one of the main reasons i ran
was just because i had the right
experience i have the right temperament
you know living you know moving to
sunnyvale 30 years ago and
getting to know people running you know
being on boards and commissions
in in non-profits that's an important
thing of understanding the fabric of
your community
and realizing how you can best help
right so i mean you you get you have the
privilege of looking at this
pandemic and you know i'm sure that
sociologists are
are having a are going to have a ball
examining you know hundreds of
of papers written on on these times and
and how social norms are differing and
how businesses are changing
the way that they're that they're
approaching this i'd love to get your
input on
you know from 30 000 feet up in the air
and obviously you're on on the ground
level all the time and you're out there
and you're talking to the individuals
but you're also overseeing the entire
city and you can see
sort of the different the different
progressions that are being made
throughout this pandemic
what's been some of the things that
maybe surprised you or that didn't
surprise you
as as this thing rolled out sure
so uh it's the biggest thing which
didn't surprise me
is um seeing how people are
trying to help out however they can you
know this is this is kind of
for me i'm super busy the hearing people
that are like bored at home i'm like
boy i wish i had that luxury a certain
degree
that being said you know seeing so many
people
you know neighborhoods joining together
to create masks
you know one of the things i did was
help network you know
people who needed elastic to create face
masks
um so people that are trying to help out
their community however they can
you know reading you know doing video
read-alongs with for kids online
you know you see all that people just
wanting to help out
but trying to stay socially distanced
is difficult and then you know working
with our business
community uh to try to figure out how to
help out so the bigger
the bigger high-tech companies you know
making those phone calls to say
can you help our sunnyvale community
services can you help
you know conceivably what we're creating
a business
um a business program to help some of
the some of the smaller businesses
through this
because sunnyvale 95 of our businesses
you know we you think we're the meeting
ground for you know facebook and apple
and google
and linkedin and all the big companies
that being said 95
of our businesses are 25 people or less
so making sure that they are you know
feeling okay
on a daily basis uh you know i'm i'm
going out and having lunch
at a different restaurant than still
that's still open talking to the owners
you know highlighting for people to to
go out and
you know still still you know shop local
you know tip the tip these people
because it's hard for restaurants right
now to stay afloat
because this is dropped off so much yeah
i don't know i mean i see
i sam i feed a lot of my friends in
sunnyvale and and this and the cities
that are surrounding
the city you know this coffee shop that
you love so much that you've been
working from
for the past 15 years well this is the
time to step up and go and buy their
supplies you know i remember that
somebody posted a picture i think it was
two three weeks ago of one of the one of
the biggest coffee shops in palo alto
they were selling their toilet paper
right basically and just as a way of you
know
and it's it's it's just unbelievable
what's happening
do you see the city changing or evolving
so
as a result of this pandemic so let's
talk about the day after
right so i you know definitely will see
a lot of businesses close you know i
think
it that's throughout the south bay we're
already seeing some businesses that say
you know clark's in mountain view set
closed after 75 years
you know or businesses that were barely
making it by before this
that now are saying you know you know
what we're not going to reopen
um that that really hits me hard but
yeah
so it's it's going out and that's one of
the reasons why
you know i'm publicizing the restaurants
that are still open and trying to make a
go
however they can definitely we will see
a change
you know i do think at least for
sunnyvale we are very well placed
to come out of the recession that that's
here that
that being said you know i wish i had a
crystal ball to say
you know this company will make it in
this company can't and who really needs
financial assistance right now um i'm
happy
i'm happy to see a lot of them change
you know it's like some of them are even
selling you know selling part of the of
the food that they get up from
from their suppliers so selling eggs
yeah and bread salting milk
just you're trying to make a go of it as
well as provide
you know additional food stuffs into the
community totally so
if there was one thing that you could
you know that if every person in the
city
would now hear you what would be one
thing that you would tell them
right now so you know from from a
business standpoint
go out and and see the restaurants go
you know go order at your favorite
restaurant go find a new restaurant
that's really critical you know they're
having a hard go of it
you know a lot of the smaller businesses
have already sheltered
that if they weren't just seen as
essential they've sheltered
um you know one of our one of our
bookstores is actually doing home
deliveries now which had never done
before
trying to pivot to make sure that they
can still provide
services into the community uh but you
know
in from a from a message to people you
make sure that they you know feel safe
you know make sure that you're healthy
that you're healthy that you're mentally
both physically and mentally healthy
getting out of the house and walking
around the block staying socially
distanced from people
but but making sure that you don't feel
completely cooped up
is critical you know because and what
people have done as far as
you know social distancing has made a
difference uh and we see we're finally
seeing the numbers
flat as far as the number of cases in
the community but
that that being said you know
it's it's difficult for everyone but we
will get through this
definitely definitely so larry we have
to stop shortly thank you again for
taking the time to do this
i have to ask you one more thing and i'm
going to put you a little bit on the
spot
what are three words that you would best
describe yourself as
or that you think other people would
describe you as
sure um let me let me i would say
compassionate
you know um inclusive
my outreach into the community has been
you know a lot of a lot of the people
you know have really appreciated that
whether or not it's the
in in sunnyvale's very diverse you know
50 of the people
weren't even born in the u.s 50 of the
people in 50
of sunnyvale really 50 percent of
sunnyvale you know for are from europe
are from asia from around the world you
know canada and mexico all over
and so 50 of more than 50 percent
weren't even born in the us
and so you know making sure that they
feel inclusive
and things always are happening you know
it's like at the federal level
especially
making you know reaching out to those
churches to those different
groups you know going to a nepali new
year so next week is
is you know nepali new year um
they they're not having their festival i
was the first council member to
to come to one of their events that
you've been having in our city
for 15 years so making sure that that
the entire community feels good you know
reaching out to the iranian church when
when you know our president
kind of pointed fingers at iran you know
about a month and a half ago two months
ago making sure that
that they feel you know that they're
part of our community and that the
mayor's ready to listen
to whatever their issues or concern are
is really important
um and then so definitely
you know compassionate feeling out uh
feeling
how i can help out in the community you
know uh inclusive
and i would say you know just generally
you know um
making uh what would be the last word uh
i would say
um positive you know you know trying to
keep a positive feel
i love it you know i i love being part
of our city
you know and and one of the things that
i've always tried to do
is make sure that that everyone feels
that they've been heard
you know and you might not be happy
about what i say
but but i meet with you know have weekly
office hours and now they move to
virtual office
hours yes but but keeping that positive
outlook that
that we will get through this and we can
deal with every issue you know it's like
it's like being an even keeled you know
leader
making sure that that everyone feels
fine feels safe
you know keeping that positive outlook
of whatever happens we will get through
it
i love it larry thank you so much for
taking the time this is fantastic
i'm happy to do it you know it's it's
always good to talk to people and
and talk about you know the good our
city is doing and and whatever
change i can do you know making sure
that people are
are feeling good about sunnyvale and
about the bay area
i love it thank you so much you're very
welcome have a good day